hi this is Prussia tall Walker I'm
pretty sure my math teacher hates me but
I really don't know why it started out
with our unit on fractions we were given
six problems for homework so I got
started with the first problem of
sixteen divided by 64 I said all right
I'll cancel out the sixes and that'll
leave me with the 1/4 I can do the same
thing on the next problem to cancel out
the sixes and that would leave me with
2/5 I was thinking this is pretty easy
so for the next problem I'll cancel out
the sixes and actually I could cancel
out the 3s as well
to get to the answer of 1/2 for the
fourth problem I couldn't cancel out any
sixes but I could cancel out the 50
fours and that would get to the answer
of five over six for the fifth problem I
looked at the top and I thought all
right there's a 42 42 on the top and a
42 42 on the bottom what remains is 4
over 7 the last problem is obviously the
hardest but I noticed something there's
a two three four five six and seven at
the top and in the bottom it's the same
digits in reverse so we cancel all those
out and then we cancel out the nine
we're left with 1/8 so I did my homework
and I even checked it on my calculator
and I was pretty sure all my answers
were correct so I should have gotten an
A but my teacher gave me a big fat F and
wrote a note see me after class I really
don't know why these are all the correct
answers
clearly my teacher hates me if you like
this video please subscribe to my
channel you can support me on patreon
catch me on my blog my near decisions on
Twitter at pressure Walker and you can
get my books listed on my website